foreign
so there is a lawyer she is a consumer
Advocate lawyer out of Hawaii okay and
she is suing
uh Romano's Macaroni Grill the
restaurant chain because she went to eat
there recently and she looked at her
receipt
her bill when she was getting ready to
sign the and they charged her a three
dollar inflation fee
they didn't tell her this when she came
to eat some pasta and she's suing them
and and she's like this is crazy bake it
into the price
I'm just telling you take it in I don't
know I like what you're doing there but
but restaurant she goes restaurants are
doing this more and more and if you're
not paying attention to it they they
come up with a term for a fee and it's a
feed you were talking about Banks and
fees yes and it made me think about this
and so I want to warn the people
because she is suing him she's going to
use a call from the Mountaintop Ken I'm
just sell from The Mountaintop I'm just
saying you better look at your receipt
because if macaroni Grill's doing it
somebody else is doing it and so they're
charging an inflation fee now here's the
deal restaurants can do anything they
want it's their business I'm all for
that yes yes all I'm saying is when I
show up and I'd say a party of five
please I would like them to say oh by
the way are you aware that we are now
charging you a three dollar inflation
fee I don't want to find out about it
after I've taken my fill of bread and
pasta yes yes do you think that that's
right
that they don't tell you about it I I
think it's not a smart business move I
don't put it so you put it in the prices
because everywhere Winston I just went
on a date night on Wednesday night we
looked at the prices and again Nashville
I guess can be bougie we were at a
pretty like Standard Restaurant I'd say
but it's just exp like we even laughed
like oh my God like you it's just a lot
like what an entree cost so I wouldn't
Flinch at my entree being an extra
dollar right fair and so put it in so I
just think it's bad business it is a
three dollar inflation fee I mean how
stupid do we do these people think we
are we're just gonna go oh well that
makes a lot of sense no you just hit me
for three dollars for nothing I mean
that's not even a real feat you just
pulled that out of here you know what
and I got to tell you I told my audience
I said let me tell you there's two ways
to go let me just tell me Ken you can go
in and ask them
I just need to know before I take my
seat
do you have an inflation fee or some
kind of no do you do that no no I
wouldn't do that I've given people who
are non-confrontational that option oh
yes I'm confrontational I love a good
confrontation I'm waiting until the bill
comes and I'm doing this number and I'm
looking at it and I'm looking I go okay
I can see there I got the antipasto I'm
going to I see that I go excuse me
ma'am sir come over here what what is
this and the waiter tells you to go I'd
like to I'd like you we have two options
here either you can tell your manager
I'm not paying for it or you can send
your manager over here and I'm going to
tell them that I'm not paying for it
that's what I would do that's what you
would do someone has to stand up against
the fees all to People by the people for
the people of a man of the people I'm
just saying that's ridiculous I know but
the thing is is you wouldn't think it's
ridiculous so they baked it into the
price of your food you wouldn't think
it's not the scenario I'm bringing in I
know I'm saying that you have to fight
for your finances people three dollars
here three dollars there that kills your
budget before you know it I'm just
telling you James somebody has
everything is not working this is a
great tease because we're actually doing
a fine print episode next season all
about Macaroni Grill so we are oh well
listen nothing against I believed you
Hey listen I like to I like to frequent
that joint they got good food but I'm
going in there and believe you me I'm
going hey Party of Five okay here's
what's fascinating to me though that she
was so she sued them this suited them
like like it like you go to lost you go
I like it no I think I just pay the fee
I don't have time okay I don't have time
in my life I want to make sure that the
people hear what's happening to deal
with that I'm anti-inflation Rachel's
like I don't care I have so much
Financial Peace that I don't care about
I went to Olive Garden and it was an
extra two bucks I am not gonna think I'm
gonna lawyer up I didn't I said go
around suing people that's I just told
her though I just said I I can't believe
she went down the road I would just pay
it and now you're saying well Rachel
will just pay us you don't care about it
inflation I'll tell you why I like it
she's an actual lawyer so she's not like
oh that's fair okay I like that it's her
Lane and she's kind of standing up for
the people yeah no I hear you I hear you
and she was I think it's three dollar
inflation fee
I mean it's ridiculous okay so what
should they do so let's say macaroni you
know what can we just talk about the
situation asked me I have an answer well
good so if macaroni girl said I am not
going to raise our prices because it is
so you know we're gonna figure out how
to do this to help the people sure we're
not raising prices everyone else says
we're not going to right but to offset
hourly wages to offset the price of food
the gas that's in the trucks that
deliver the food are charging us more
we're just getting charged more to run
business today which is what's happening
yeah so if every customer pays an extra
three bucks it helps us keep the food
costs down of what the customer has to
pay
and it's great how about
how about you come out and say you know
what we as Macaroni Grill are not going
to charge you a three dollar inflation
fee here's what we're going to do we're
going to keep prices the same because we
know that everybody wants to go out and
have a nice meal every once in a while
so we're going to be the restaurant
chain who doesn't Jack our prices
because as a corporation we make a good
amount of money and we'd love for you to
support us now you know what happened
everybody would go let's go to Macaroni
Grill and everybody's going to tip the
waiters and waitresses very nicely well
I see on the board here Rick has
something about restaurants are getting
discounts now this is talk radio Okay
live reaction Rick Rick are you hearing
us chat about Macaroni Grill
yes I did how you doing today good great
what say you Rick
um what a lot of restaurants around here
are doing which I'm surprised they
didn't do it in the beginning because
anytime you use a card those businesses
are getting charged by the people that
process the payments yep yep so what the
restaurants are doing around here
there's been two or three of them here
in our area locally here that uh what
they're doing is if you pay cash you pay
a cheaper rate and they're basically if
you use a card then they're passing that
payment on so that's a way for them not
to have great prices
too love it that is see now that's
innovation without sticking it to the
little guy who just wants some
breadsticks you know
that's so good Rick
thanks for calling in on that because
that's a great thank you Rick so
restaurants out there yeah Rick makes an
excellent point
inflation everybody Stand Together take
your Rachel Cruz wallet take out the out
to eat money add the cash and you get
charged there
then if you used a card because there's
no fees for the merchant all right see
this is how we fight inflation how do we
how do we think through this America you
know what we ought to do James 30 days
all Americans decide we're only going to
eat stuff in our house we're gonna go on
a spending freeze watch Target Walmart
Kroger and all of them drop prices
stick that in your pipe and smoke it
this might be the only thing that can
unite America
United again Ken and Rachel for America